All right, so we see that the code
with the single bracket and
a percent sign on either side
is the logical code that we
want to execute in our HTML,
like a for loop.
The double brackets indicate the code
that we want it's results printed into
the html document itself.
Since, from within HTML codes,
we cannot use indentations to mark
the beginning and ending of statements
and loops, we must use keywords,
like endfor, and endif, to indicate
the end of a loop, or statement.
Going back to my menu.html, I can
see how I'm obtaining the result of
a query and executing the output
here in my HTML page.
I will also need to substitute the code
I had in my restaurant menu method, so
that instead of returning a string,
we will return a rendered template
with the new menu.html file.
Since I'm querying on my restaurant and
menu items table, I will path my queries
into the template, so that my escape
code has access to these variables.
I will also need to import
the render_template function from my
Flask library.
By saving and refreshing the page,
I see the same code with
a few stylistic modifications
I added inside of my template.
You'll be building your
own templates very soon.
I just want to talk about two more
topics to help you get the most out of
them first.